[Musique]
et cette semaine j'ai envie de vous
parler du fait que le Vatican a
finalement répudié 500 ans plus tard la
doctrine de la découverte et ça c'est un
moment historique très important mais
qui sent le pas réveiller
beaucoup de réactions dans les diverses
consciences parce que on comprend pas
l'ampleur de ce que c'est mais la
doctrine la découverte terrain du lieu
par exemple sont les pierres angulaires
sur lesquelles on a permis aux grandes
couronnes d'Europe de pouvoir venir
exploiter et coloniser les Amériques
mais c'est très très large c'est très en
même temps dur à calculer mais
aujourd'hui je peux vous parler encore
du fait que c'est l'impact de terrain
nulus de la doctrine de la découverte se
fait encore sentir dans nos communautés
dans nos relations justement avec Lisa
l'automne et je vais essayer de vous
mettre ça en place de façon très large
parce que c'est quand même assez grand
comme impact
c'est l'idée qu'il n'y avait personne
sur ses terres donc on pouvait planter
son drapeau mettre sa petite croix
nommer ça ici parce que tout ce qui
avait c'était des arbres des animaux et
des sauvages c'était la réflexion qui
avait à l'époque et comme c'était appuyé
par l'Église Vatican les courants se
sentaient beaucoup plus
apte de pouvoir faire ses actions là de
colonisation que si ça avait été par
exemple des gens qui étaient considérés
comme des humains ce qui aurait pas été
très très chrétiens mais comme ils
étaient pas convertis à la religion on
pouvait bien sûr commencer à les
convertir et donc à
les rendre humain c'est ça c'est
carrément ça parce que c'était une
manière de déshumaniser les personnes
qui habitaient déjà sur ces continents
là en disant qu'il n'avaient ni culture
ni religion ni passer ce n'était que des
ours ou des écureuils dans le fond mais
on le sait nous civilisation était très
riches notre histoire était présente
depuis des temps immémoriaux donc vous
comprenez que c'était un impôt un
important construit intellectuel et
psychologique pour les gens devenir ici
et de finalement
prendre possession des terres des corps
humain aussi ça a été vu dans plusieurs
autres formes de colonisation mais cette
réflexion là à l'inspiré quand même
autant en Amérique du Sud en Amérique
centrale puis en Amérique du Nord la
manière dont on allait
interagir avec les autres humains qui
existaient sur ces tailles bien sûr
aujourd'hui on a déjà imaginé comment
une politique de 500 ans des écrits des
édits de il y a 500 ans peuvent encore
avoir des impacts aujourd'hui mais on a
pu suivre tranquillement à travers les 7
l'impact de cette réflexion là
que ce soit par exemple dans les causes
aux États-Unis où on disait que bien
depuis avoir vraiment de reconnaissance
d'existence puisque vous n'étiez pas là
tout le temps en continu alors qu'on le
sait on les communautés ont été
déplacées et c'est même que permis à
aux États-Unis un grand moment
historique c'est-à-dire la découverte de
l'Ouest c'est toute la culture autour
des cowboys des Indiens c'était vraiment
basé sur tes renus qui était aussi
traduit dans une autre forme de pensée
qui s'appelle le manifeste Destiny le
manifeste Destiny était de dire qu'on
amenait les lumières de l'Est vers
l'Ouest sauvage donc c'est encore une
fois cette idée que les cultures qui
existaient sur ces territoires là
n'était pas valide ne valait rien donc
on pouvait signer des traités on pouvait
s'entendre autour de de relation
d'amitié et après ça briser ses
promesses d'ailleurs le Canada les
États-Unis s'est reconnu des traités ont
signé mais jamais respecté
les territoires ont été conquis non pas
par des guerres mais par des poignées de
main et des promesses d'amitié donc vous
voyez comment en
respectant pas la vision de l'autre en
ne les voyant pas comme humain on
pouvait se permettre de mentir encore
aujourd'hui beaucoup de cette réflexion
existe dans les interactions entre à
l'octone et autochtone
pour quiconque peut partager
cette expérience là moi j'ai déjà
entendu ben si on avait pas été là vous
seriez encore des sauvages vous seriez
vous auriez possibilité
où le fait que on va pas donner le
Canada là il est trop tard mais si
quelqu'un dit que te voler quelque chose
tu es obligé de leur donner pourquoi
est-ce que l'idée que l'indback serait
pas valide comme un mode de modification
dans la relation entre le Canada et les
communautés autochtones bien c'est à
cause qu'il y a encore cette idée qu'on
pas encore assez humain où on n'est pas
encore assez valide pour défaire les
impacts de la colonisation pour pouvoir
aussi réparer les impacts de la
colonisation parce qu'il faut pas
oublier que quand on suit cette pensée
qui était granuleuse qui était la
doctrine de la découverte et bien on a
les pensionnats les réserves on a le
sexisme coupe on a le racisme
institutionnalisé on a des
problématiques avec les gens au
quotidien qui se voient encore et qui se
ressentent même moi pendant ma jeunesse
maintenant encore aujourd'hui à ce jour
comme étant le fait que nous ne sommes
moins valides que des citoyens à
l'automne qui se sont installés à
travers justement la colonisation mais
cette réflexion là aujourd'hui elle peut
avoir enfin un inversement de vapeur de
la machine puisque le Vatican celui qui
avait validé cette réflexion là au début
avec la doctrine a découverte et bien
maintenant dit que ce n'est plus valide
que ça ne peut pas exister et que ça a
été faux dès le début et
maintenant c'est de voir quel impact
cela aura sur les relations futures
c'est certain que maintenant on peut
plus faire semblant que ça n'existe pas
on peut pas faire semblant non plus que
on a gagné des gars contre les
autochtones donc on a signé des packs ou
des traités de vente ce n'est pas vrai
c'est un parcours qui est légal qui est
reconnu dans la Constitution canadienne
et qui ne peut plus être lu d'un point
de vue du gagnant et du perdant alors
qu'il n'y avait pas ça au début il y
avait des relations d'amitié on s'est
fait tendre le bras donc ça peut être
intéressant ça va être confrontant aussi
puisque la doctrine la découverte ça va
donner quand même la plus grosse part du
gâteau à quelqu'un et malheureusement
des certaines fois certains des
héritiers de la doctrine de la
découverte de la doctrine de terrain
nulus aujourd'hui trouve ça très
difficile de voir qu'ils ont entre les
mains des privilèges qui sont irrités de
générations en génération d'une doctrine
qui aujourd'hui comme raciste et
problématique
on va voir combien de gens vont nous
dire de nous en remettre combien de gens
vont dire que le Canada peut pas être
redonné mais c'est clairement encore une
fois une victoire morale pour les
communautés autochtones et maintenant de
voir comment ça va se traduire au niveau
légal c'est ce qui reste intéressant à
voir à l'horizon alors je vous souhaite
une belle semaine j'espère que vous
allez vous intéresser à un terrain nulus
j'espère que vous comprenez que ça va
amener énormément de discussions
énormément de problématiques aussi dans
les discussions mais c'est une question
d'avenir et même en fait en même temps
une question du passé alors je vous
souhaite une belle semaine